i am laura ingram this ingram angle from
washington tonight once again some bide
administration official is leaking
evidence about the trump raid after
business hours now this time the leakers
gave a big fat wet kiss to the
washington post phrases like a person
familiar with the investigation or
people familiar were used nine times to
describe the months long back and forth
between the bite administration and the
former president now
these leaks are totally devastating to
the government's credibility
now this it's the same drip drip drip
tactics that they used in the russia
collusion investigation this is so
familiar it's almost boring i almost
didn't want to start with it tonight but
remember how the media they keep
insisting that everything had to be
secret it's the secrecy is the most
important thing but now we have the
administration leaking to the post and
of course new york times
on back to back days and yet democrats
and prominent republicans you know who
you are
are claiming that it's outrageous for
anyone to go on to criticize the fbi or
the doj that we should all trust the
leadership of both doj and the fbi
just because i guess some nostalgia i
don't know
but the time for blind reverence is over
the time for tough questions and
accountability
begins now
we're going to have much more on this
later in the show
but first
faking it not making it that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
all right we had huge reaction to last
night's angle on the obvious efforts to
psych out republican voters before the
midterms so we urge mitch mcconnell to
leave the punditry and the odds making
to others and actually to start leading
the party toward victory
but of course the media has glommed onto
mcconnell's recent columnist
mitch mcconnell
recently said that he felt like the
senate could actually go either way sort
of surprising to come from him he said
that the quality of candidates will be
an important factor i love that he said
that anne marie the quality of
candidates
i mean we're talking about herschel
walker who's been caught up in a variety
of controversies
you mentioned dr
oz uh
and even in arizona there are people who
are looking at arizona and saying you
know what senator mark kelly has a good
chance of keeping that seat
wow he's so smart
now while the gop establishment signals
to everyone of course that the populist
they can't win never never can they win
the democrats are so convinced that the
populist can win that they nominated
john uncle festerman and tim ryan their
senate candidates in pennsylvania and
ohio
who are both pretending to be populous
in an effort to hold off oz and vance
who are actual populous
now here's uncle festerman today acting
like he's the man of the people
if i'm your next
senator to washington d.c guess what
you're still going to have a senator
that's going to be living across the
street from your steel plant i'm going
to be the kind of senator that's going
to be living directly across the street
with a union hall
is that the roommate the union hall
now if fetterman and ryan are populous
then i'm a woke left winger
those two men are of course just
misleading the voters
if either of them win
they'll be rubber stamps for joe biden
and chuck schumer and those guys aren't
looking out for the average american we
know that
so you know that when tim ryan says
something like this well he's lying
i don't answer to any political party i
answer to the folks i grew up with and
the families like yours all across ohio
i'll work with either party to cut costs
and pass a middle-class tax cut
does anyone wear a jacket a tie any
longer this is the casual athleisure
wear aren't we tired of that by the way
a tax cut that he's talking about he
just voted to pass the so-called
inflation reduction act another lie of a
title which according to the cbo raises
taxes on the middle class nice going mr
populist and he's playing the moderate
card that's just complete crap he voted
with joe biden and nancy pelosi 100 of
the time
that's just so far this congress now the
democrats have fooled themselves with
this type of ploy before remember john
tester he pulled it in montana
mark kelly pulled it in arizona and the
famous joe manchin he pulled it in west
virginia but it always ends up the same
those guys might lie but the raw numbers
do not
here's how more of the so-called
moderate democrats voted as compared to
their party leadership so far this
congress
georgia senator rafael warnock voted
with schumer 97 of the time and 96 with
biden nevada senator catherine cortez
masto also voted 97 with schumer nearly
93 percent of the time with biden and
arizona senator mark the astronaut kelly
is 96 with chuck schumer over 94
with biden
committed liberals every single one of
them
and now they'll have another scam to
line up behind tomorrow joe biden is
expected to unilaterally just grant ten
thousand dollars in student loan
forgiveness for every borrower with less
income
with an income less than 125 thousand
dollars now not only
is that constitutionally suspect
the penn wharton budget model finds that
would add 330 billion to the dollars the
deficit
it's so outrageous i can't even say the
line okay
not to mention it's the opposite of
being populist it's just a bribe to win
back young liberal well-to-do voters
blue-collar workers out there sorry
you're out of luck no help for you
now get this the richest 40 of americans
they carry 60 of the student loan debt
while the bottom 40 percent just 20
and minorities
sorry it doesn't help you either
the naacp came out swinging immediately
on this saying we've got a problem this
is not how you treat black voters whoops
come on joe biden doesn't care though
and neither does his fake populist pals
who just want votes like senator warnock
who already signed on to a letter
supporting such a move this happened
this past march expect others to quickly
follow
now the democrat party will continue to
push for higher gas prices controlling
what your kids learn in school and
restrictions on everything from beef
to air conditioning
and the fake populace in the democrat
party support that agenda all the way
down the line
faking it but not making it as a true
populist not on the border and certainly
not on china so don't be surprised for
one moment a fetterman orion at times
they try to sound like donald trump
the democrats know the you know the
political appeal of populism even if
some in the gop establishment still
haven't figured it out
but the democrats have no intention of
governing on a populist agenda the
moment the election is over and all the
streamers and all the confetti it's all
swept away
biden and his team will be back to
lowering our standards of living and
guys like fetterman and ryan will be
with them every step of the way
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else